Мисливець, якого переслідує його ж мисливська вишка.
Фермер, який лопатою наткнувся на гейзер.
І гордість автопрому соціалістичної НДР
Трабант у запеклих автоперегонах із
сучасним Фольксвагеном.
Усі ці вистави - частина мистецької акції "Рухома земля",
яку розробили спеціально для пасажирів потягів.
На 30-кілометровому відрізку між Наумбургом у Саксонії-Ангальті
та Єною в Тюрингії місцеві жителі створюють
рухомий театр для подорожуючих потягами.
"Це змушує людей не дивитися у свій смартфон
чи в монітор ноутбука.
Натомість люди бачать чудовий ландшафт
та магічні пейзажі, і, звісно ж, до цього їх спонукають
ці специфічні дотатки до звичного виду з вікна".
"Це створює чудовий настрій!"
Далі на маршруті з’являються люди з кам’яної доби.
І рибалки, яких налякала акула у прісній воді.
Ідея такого театру належить медіа-митцям
Йорну Гінтцеру та Якобу Гюфнеру.
15 років тому ви й уявити не могли б,
що за день в Інтернеті перед вами на відстані
одного кліку проноситимуться 15 тисяч картинок.
Те саме ми намагаємося відтворити під час руху потяга.
Це аналогія з новими медіа.
Картинки проносяться швидко і вони
жодним чином  не по’вязані одна з одною,
однак цих ескізів доволі багато.
Сотні волонтерів беруть участь у проекті.
В селищі Дьобрітшен
майже всі його мешканці вийшли у поле з драбинами.
Ідея цієї сцени полягає в тому,
щоб стати на один рівень з пасажиром і заглянути в потяг.
Це неймовірне відчуття брати в цьому участь
і те, що мешканці селища залучені до цього.
Принаймні, ми проведемо чудовий вікенд.
Люди зможуть краще розгледіти наші сільські місця.
У нас тут не типовий туристичний регіон,
тож можливо цей перфоманс привабить більше відвідувачів.
А згодом Рокко починає бігти наввипередки з потягом.
Фокус у тому: що 25 ідентично одягнених бігунів
створюють враження, що людина біжить швидше за потяг.
Або випереджає потяг на велосипеді.
Звичайно ж, у потяга не було шансів виграти у Рокко.
Загалом за два дні актори дали свої вистави
для 24-х потягів, переповнених пасажирами.
Для живих кущів - це означало бігати через все поле двічі на годину.
Цей мистецький проект надихнув усіх:
і учасників, і тих, хто спостерігав за дійством з вікна потяга.